Black Panther is already being hailed as
an astonishing installment to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with tight direction
top-of-the-line performances and
stunning action sequences the studio's
had no trouble commanding an audience
over the last decade of course but with
black panther it looks like they're
developing a truly special cinematic
experience and here's why behind the
lens talent black panther might only be
director Ryan Coogler 'he's third
feature film but there are plenty of
reasons Marvel trusted him to kick off
its all-new franchise for starters even
though his filmography is limited it's
still quite impressive his first feature
Fruitvale station when the Grand Jury
Prize at Sundance and garnered near
universal acclaim and his second movie
Creed instantly became known as one of
the best entries in the rocky series and
cleaned up at the box office too perhaps
most importantly he also just so happens
to be a lifelong black panther superfan
which was a big factor in the hiring
process
Marvel Studios head honcho Kevin Feige
told Entertainment Weekly koogler made
the film for his eight-year-old self
most importantly you'd do it for other
eight-year-olds to inspire the next
generation the way we were inspired and
in this case when Ryan was growing up
perhaps there weren't that many of these
heroes to be inspired by that looked
like it appears that having someone with
a real heart for the art at the helm
obviously paid off here
a true leading man T'Challa was
introduced to film audiences in 2016 s
Captain America Civil War a movie
already stuffed to the brim with heroes
even though the movie had a frenetic
pace and tons of Heroes to deal with
chadwick boseman regal performance
really sold audiences on the wakandans
superhero and in black panther he
steadily commands the screen as the
rousing royal I am Randy perhaps it's no
surprise that bowsman is impressing
audiences in the film after all he'd
already been a cinematic force with
leading roles in movies like 42 and get
on up compelling villainy no Ryan
Coogler film would be complete without
the director's muse Michael B Jordan the
actor starred in both of cooler's prior
pictures and this time he's getting to
do something totally new Jordan stars in
Black Panther as Eric hill monger an
exiled wakandan turned us black ops
soldier who returns to challenge two
chawla or the throne as with his last
two Kugler collaborations Jordan's work
in the film is already being hailed as
the
MC you villain since Loki considering
how much travel Marvel movies have had
making satisfying screen baddies lately
that's high praise for the red-hot
actors work in the movie scene stealers
with all the a-listers starring in Black
Panther it might be hard to believe that
an up-and-comer has emerged as the scene
stealer of the whole film but that's
exactly what happened with Leticia
Wright as Sheree
you might recognize right as Rini in
humans or nish in black mirrors black
Museum episode but after Black Panther
she's bound to be as big of a star as
anyone else on the film's roster the
character is brilliant sprightly and a
complete standout that'll definitely
make audiences smile and Sheree isn't
the only one with some major girl power
in Black Panther the characters of koay
and Nakia played by denis Guria and
Lupita Nyong'o respectively have also
received high marks for badassery mood
music
if the filmmaking and acting talent
involved in the film wasn't impressive
enough the film's soundtrack is also
brimming with exciting voices Kendrick
Lamar produced the album and managed to
round up hip-hop favorites like
schoolboy q Vince staples future The
Weeknd and scissor to contribute tracks
alongside Lamar himself Marvel's
guardians of the galaxy soundtracks
might have made waves for reviving some
old favorites but black panther is
taking things a step further with an
original album that's already got people
talking action satisfaction it just
wouldn't be a Marvel movie without a ton
of action packed set pieces and black
panther delivers on that angle just as
well as everywhere else the film's fight
scenes have drawn comparisons to slick
action fare like the Kingsmen and James
Bond series for their sophistication
levels and there's at least one massive
chase scene that should get audiences
adrenaline properly pumping as well
post-credit impact another signature
Marvel move is to include post-credit
sequences and the two featured in black
panther seemed to be signals for what's
ahead without spoiling them let's just
say that they point to a brave new
future for the Kingdom of Wakanda and
connect the dots between prior Marvel
films and what's to come with Avengers
infinity war cultural pride it's no
secret that Western films have a history
of portraying African nations as being
impoverished and violent however with a
mainstream
film like this one showcasing more of
the vibrant and beautiful aspects of
African culture the film has the
potential to change the way Hollywood
treats the birthplace of humanity as
Lupita Nyong'o who is raised in Kenya
put it marvel has a way of really
affecting popular culture and to have
that popular culture informed with
things that are of African origin is
powerful
hopefully it changes the general idea of
what being an African is too often times
we see Africa as a place that is wanting
and here it's a place that you want to
go so beyond just being entertainment
black panther could very well represent
a moment of cultural awakening
altogether the way that the film's
talent celebrated native fashion at the
premiere it seems to have already
arrived as a source of pride not only
that but the movie could also reshape
the way studios think about black cinema
as a whole lately black directors have
been having more and more success
getting their stories on the screens
Googlers contemporaries such as Ava
Duvernay and Jordan Peele have been
steadily proving that cinematic stories
told from a black cultural viewpoint can
not only give young black audiences the
kind of representation they've been
yearning for but also generate boatloads
of cash perhaps it'll take a pop-culture
Titan like Marvel to drive this point
home once and for all but if it does
Black Panther could be a serious
game-changer thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel let's check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]